I'M GOING TO CALL
THIS SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING TO ORDER WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM RIGHT NOW, BUT
I'LL START WITH OUR OBLIGATORY
EARLY ANNOUNCEMENTS. UM. THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL COME TO
ORDER WE ARE LIVE IN ROOM 2200
OF THE SWING SPACE. I ASK THAT
ALL MEMBERS COME DOWN TO BEGIN
THE HEARING. WE HAVE 21 BILLS ON
THE AGENDA, ALL OF WHICH ARE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
INDICATED THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE
FILES FOR ANY OF THE BILLS BUT
ARE PRESENT FOR QUESTIONS. UM
BEFORE WE BEGIN, I STILL CAN'T
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. UM SO I WANT
TO REMIND THE WITNESSES WHO ARE
GOING TO TESTIFY TO CONFINE
THEIR TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL AND REFRAIN
FROM PRIOR LITIGATING THE POLICY
MERITS. UM AND SO IF YOU ALL
COULD OBLIGED AND KEEPING YOUR
COMMENTS TO THE FISCAL WE WILL
BE GOING IN ORDER WITH SP 26 OUR
FIRST BILL UP, BUT WE'LL GIVE A
MINUTE HERE TO SEE IF WE GET A
CHOIR. UM NO LUCK. NO LUCK.
OKAY. I APPRECIATE TRY. WHILE
WE'RE AT IT, DO WE WANT AN EASY
OR HARD TRIVIA QUESTION TO START
TRIVIA. SOFTBALL YOU WANT A
SOFTBALL? OH MY GOODNESS. ALL
RIGHT. WHAT DOES WWW STAND FOR
IN A WEBSITE BROWSER? WORLDWIDE
WAY WAS A SOFTBALL. HOW ABOUT A
LITTLE HARDER? HOW LONG IS AN
OLYMPIC SWIMMING POOL IN METERS?
50 M. UM HERE'S ANOTHER EASY
ONE. WHAT COUNTRY DO THE CITIES
OF PERTH, ADELAIDE AND BRISBANE
BELONG TO AUSTRALIA, AUSTRALIA.
HERE'S A HARD ONE. WHAT
GEOMETRIC SHAPE IS A GENERALLY
USED FOR A STOP SIGN. AFTER
OCTAGON. WHO NAMED THE PACIFIC
OCEAN. WASN'T COLUMBUS. THAT'S
WHAT GOD GOD KNOWS. FERDINAND
MAGELLAN. ROBERT GOT THAT. HOW
MANY HERE'S A HARD ONE. HOW MANY
COUNTRIES STILL HAVE THE
SHILLING AS A CURRENCY? WHO
KNOWS? FOUR. CAN ANYBODY NAME
THEM? KENYA UGANDA, TANZANIA AND
SOMALIA ALL USE THE SHIPPING.
ADVICE ALRIGHT. WE STARTED WITH
A FEW TRIVIA QUESTIONS. WE STILL
DON'T HAVE A CAR, BUT WE'RE
GOING TO OPEN UP AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND WE'RE GOING TO
OPEN UP WITH SB 26, WHICH IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE, THE AUTHORS
WAVE PRESENTATION SO WE WILL GO
TO OUR WITNESSES. WE ARE NOT
DOING REMOTE TESTIMONY TODAY. SO
ONLY, UH IN PERSON. SO DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES FOR US B 26?
SEEING NO ONE COMING TO THE
MICROPHONE. WE HAVE ANYBODY
OPPOSED. SB 26. SAYING NOBODY
COME TO THE MICROPHONE. WE HAVE
NO FILE. DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES?
SEEING NO QUESTION. SO WHEN WE
HAVE A WHEN WE HAVE A CHOIR, UM
WE WILL DEAL WITH SB 26, BY THE
WAY THAT WAS ON MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONS CARE SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM BY SENATOR AMBERG SB 850
, WHICH IS SENATOR UMBERG, WHICH
IS ON COURTS NOTIFICATION SYSTEM
. IT'S ALSO A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING
WITH ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM
WANTING TO TESTIFY AND SB 850.
WE HAVE NOBODY COMING IN SUPPORT
ANY OPPOSITION? SB 850 SEEING NO
OPPOSITION. HOW ABOUT WE COME
BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES ON
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS RELATED TO
SB 850? SEEING NONE. WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM, WE WILL DEAL WITH
SB 850. SB 53 PORTANTINO ON
FIREARMS STORAGE. WE WILL OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT WITH
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT. SB 53
SEEING NO ONE COMING TO SUPPORT.
HOW ABOUT OPPOSITION? COME ON
UP. THANK YOU, MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. WE
STAND IN OPPOSITION TO SB 53 AND
SEPARATORS, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF GUN OWNERS OF CALIFORNIA,
ALSO REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION AND
THE NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION.
WITH REGARDS TO THE FISCAL
ASPECTS OF THIS BILL, IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE TO US AT A TIME WHEN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS TENS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS UPSIDE
DOWN. THAT THEY WOULD GO TO
COURT AND SPEND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS, IF NOT MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON A LAWSUIT THAT THEY
CANNOT WIN. IT IS IMPOSSIBLE
THAT THIS ISSUE WILL MAKE IT
THROUGH THE LEGAL PROCESS
BECAUSE THE SUPREME COURT HAS
ALREADY RULED TWICE THAT THIS
BILL SPECIFICALLY IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. SO IT TROUBLES
ME THAT THAT THAT THE STATE WILL
GO AHEAD AND SPEND THOSE
RESOURCES AND IT EVEN TROUBLES
ME MORE THAT THAT IS MY TAX
DOLLARS THAT ARE GOING TO THE
STATE AND THEN COMING BACK TO
PAY OUR ATTORNEY'S FEES. WHICH
ALLOWS US TO CONTINUE TO
CHALLENGE MANY UNCONSTITUTIONAL
LAW. SO FOR THESE REASONS, AND
OTHERS WERE IN OPPOSITION TO
SEND A BILL 53 THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE SUPPOSED TO SB 53 SEEING
NONE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES SEEING NONE.
WE WILL DEAL WITH THAT WHEN WE
HAVE A QUARTER MOVING ON SB 691
PORTANTINO STATE COURT OF
EDUCATION STUDENT MEMBERS WE'LL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING FOR
SUPPORT. SEEING NO SUPPORT. HOW
ABOUT OPPOSITION TO 691? SEEING
NO OPPOSITION IS 691 ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES? SEEING NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
WE WILL DEAL WITH THAT WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM AND AGAIN, AS
NOTED, MICHELLE SAYS THERE ARE
NO FILES FROM THE FINANCE SP 230
FROM MY COLLEAGUE, MR SARTO ON
INCOME TAX HEALTH SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS. IT'S A TAX LEVY. WE
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT
WITH THAT. SEEING NO ONE COME IN
SUPPORT. HOW ABOUT OPPOSITE?
COME ON UP. WE'RE MOVING
QUICKLY. THANK YOU, SENATOR TIM
MADDEN, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS
IN SUPPORT. MR MADDEN? YES SIR.
HARD QUESTION. WHAT IS THE NAME
OF THE MAN WHO LAUNCHED EBAY IN
1995 PEER OLDER MIRER. DIRE?
YES. GOOD GOOD. GOOD. GOOD THAT
WAS GOOD. VERY GOOD. I THOUGHT
YOU WOULD LIFT THAT ONE. ALRIGHT
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF 230
THE OPPOSITION TO 230. SEEING NO
OPPOSITION, AND HE COMMENTS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES. PEANUT GALLERY.
SPOKEN ALREADY. SEEING NO
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES. WE
WILL DEAL WITH 230 WHEN IT COMES
WHEN WE HAVE A CHOIR. UM SENATOR
WEINER HAS TWO BILLS. SB 294
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE. INDEPENDENT
MEDICAL REVIEW. UM, SUPPORT.
NICOLE WARD ULLMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP AND
SUPPORT DO YOU WANT TO QUESTION
NICOLE? SURE. WHICH MONARCH
OFFICIALLY MADE VALENTINE'S DAY
A HOLIDAY IN 1537. NOPE. ANYBODY
KNOW? HENRY THE EIGHTH. ISN'T
THAT INTERESTING? HE HAD A LOT
OF THINGS TO TALK ABOUT ON
VALENTINE'S DAY. ALRIGHT ANY
OPPOSITION TO 94? SEEING NO ONE
COME TO THE MICROPHONE. HOW
ABOUT FROM MY COLLEAGUES? ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON 294
SEEING? NONE. WE WILL DEAL WITH
THAT WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM. SB
312 FROM SENATOR WEINER AND
CALIFORNIA IN ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY UNIVERSITY HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS EXEMPTION.
IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE, THE
OTHERS WAY PRESENTATION. WE HAVE
NO FILE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING AND 312. NO ONE
IN SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION SEEING
NO OPPOSITION. WE WILL COME TO
THE DAY S ANYONE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MR WEINER'S 312
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP. WE'LL
DEAL WITH THAT. WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM, SENATOR CORTEZ HE HAS SB
483 ON PUPIL RIGHT PRONE
RESTRAINT. IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AND YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. NICOLE WARDIMAN OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP AND
SUPPORT. WANT AN EASY ONE OR
HARD ONE. NICOLE I THINK I'VE
SHOWN I NEED AN EASY ONE. OKAY.
WHAT IS THE NAME OF THE WORLD'S
LARGEST OCEAN? OH, MY GOODNESS.
OKAY IT IS THAT THE PACIFIC
THANK YOU, SIR. PACIFIC RIGHT?
THE PACIFIC OCEAN. ALRIGHT. ANY
OPPOSITION TO MR CORTEZ EASE FOR
83 SEEING NO OPPOSITION. LET'S
COME BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES. WE
HAVE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. BUT SO WE WILL DEAL
WITH THAT IN A SECOND, BUT WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM. AND SO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH ACQUIRE. UM PORTANTINO
HERE. PORTANTINO HERE, JONES.
ASHBY. BRADFORD BRADFORD HERE
SEE ARTO TOHIR HOB HOB HERE,
WIENER. WE HAVE A CHOIR. UM ALL
RIGHT, SO THAT BEING SAID, LET'S
GO BACK TO SB 26 SENATOR UMBERG
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SP 26 WILL
MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE FILE. SB
850 SENATOR AMBERG WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AS THE 850 WILL MOVE
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE. SB 53
PORTANTINO FIREARMS STORAGE
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SP 53 WILL
MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE FILE SP 691
PORTANTINO STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION. WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB
691 WILL MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE. SB 230 SEYARTO INCOME TAX
HEALTH SAVINGS ACCOUNTS WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SB 231 MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. SP 294 WIENER
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE. INDEPENDENT
MEDICAL REVIEW WITHOUT OBJECTION
, SP 294 WILL MOVE TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. SB 312 WIENER
CALIFORNIA QUALITY ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT UNIVERSITY HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SP 312 AND MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE S BEFORE 83, WHICH WE JUST
TOOK PUBLIC TESTIMONY FROM
BEFORE 83 CORTE ZING ON PUPIL
RIGHTS WITHOUT OBJECTION. MOVED
TO THE SUSPENSE. FILES SO WE'VE
CAUGHT UP BUSINESS. MS WAHAB.
WANT AN EASY OR A HARD QUESTION.
WHICHEVER OKAY, WHAT IS THE MOST
CONSUMED MANUFACTURED DRINK IN
THE WORLD. COCA COLA. MM.
COFFEE. CLOSE. T T. ALL RIGHT,
TRY. I'LL GIVE YOU THE EASY ONE
WHICH YOU WOULD BE. WHAT WAS THE
FIRST SOFT DRINK THAT WAS DRUNK
IN SPACE. COCA COLA, COCA COLA.
THERE YOU GO. ALL RIGHT. MOVING
ON TO SENATOR LAMONTAGNE SP 533
ON INCOME TAX CREDIT CHILD
CHILDCARE. IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. THE AUTHORS WAVED
PRESENTATION. AND WE WILL OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT RIGHT HERE
IN THIS ROOM FOR 533. ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT, SEEING NO SUPPORT. ANY
OPPOSITION TO 533 NO OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT. WE'LL COME BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUE'S ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON 533. SAYING NONE
WITH SO WITHOUT OBJECTION. 533
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 782
LIMÓN ON GUBERNATORIAL
APPOINTMENTS. IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE, THE AUTHOR'S WAY
PRESENTATION. WE WILL OPEN UP
PUBLIC COMMENT WITH SUPPORT. HI
GOOD MORNING TURNED MEMBERS VERY
QUICKLY. CAROL GONZALEZ HERE ON
BEHALF OF HOPE FINANCE,
ORGANIZED FOR POLITICAL EQUALITY
IN LIGHT OF THE LATEST VETO FROM
THE GOVERNOR HOPE INITIATED A
QUICK, THOROUGH ANALYSIS ON THE
GUBERNATORIAL APPOINTMENT THIS
LAST YEAR. THEY UNCOVERED VERY
CRITICAL DATA POINTS THAT SHOW
THAT THERE ARE THERE'S STILL
GREAT GAPS IN REPRESENTATION
ACROSS THE STATE. IF HOPE WAS
ABLE TO CURATE THIS KIND OF
REPORT FOR SB SEVEN OUT 782
DESPITE NOT HAVING DIRECT ACCESS
TO DATA AND LIMITED FUNDS, WE
CERTAINLY THINK THAT
MINISTRATIONS CAN LEAD THIS
EFFORT AND PUBLISH IT IN HOUSE
REPORT. AS WE 782 ONLY REQUIRES
THE ADMINISTRATION TO ANNUALLY
REPORT THIS DATA, WHICH MEANS
THAT THIS IS SIMPLE, BUT
EFFECTIVE BILL CAN COME AT
NEARLY NO COST TO THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS, WE PROUDLY SPONSORED
THIS BILL AND HOPE FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. DO YOU WANT TO QUESTION
OKAY? YES OH, REALLY? ALRIGHT.
MR WIENER. HERE'S A QUESTION FOR
YOU. WHICH IS THE ONLY EDIBLE
FOOD THAT NEVER GOES BAD. WHAT
DO YOU MEAN? WHAT DO YOU MEAN
EDIBLE FOOD. DOES THAT INCLUDE,
LIKE FAKE FOOD OR THE ONLY F NO.
ANY FOOD THAT YOU EAT THE ONLY
FOOD PRODUCT THAT NEVER GOES
BAD, NEVER SPOILS. UM I HEARD
THE AUDIENCE SAY IT BUT WATER.
WHO WAS IT? HONEY HONEY? HONEY
NEVER GOES BAD. HOW ABOUT THAT?
ALRIGHT HERE'S ANOTHER ANOTHER
FOOD RELATED QUESTION. WHICH
COUNTRY INVENTED ICE CREAM. WHO
KNOWS WHO INVENTED ICE CREAM.
CAPTAIN ROBERT. THE. STORE IN
CHINA BASKET RIGHT NOW TRYING TO
INVENTED ICE CREAM, ALL RIGHT?
MOVING ON TO ANY OPPOSITION TO
SB 782 LIMÓN. SEEING NO
OPPOSITION. ANY COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES? SEEING NONE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. 782 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 546 ALVARADO GIL.
SALES AND USE TAX LAW EXEMPTION
DEDICATED SNOW REMOVAL VEHICLES.
IT IS A TAX LEVY WELL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENT WITH SUPPORT
SEEING NO SUPPORT. HOW ABOUT
OPPOSITION TO 546 SEEING NO
OPPOSITION TO MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT SB 546 OR
COMMENTS SEEING NONE SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SB 546 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SP 559 MEN OFFSHORE
OIL DRILLING LEASES. IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. THE AUTHOR'S
WAY PRESENTATION AND YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. YES, THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHRISTINA SURRENDERED
THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY, ALSO NOTING SUPPORT
FROM HEAL THE BAY, CALIFORNIA
OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION IS AT THE
END OF ITS LIFE CYCLE, AND THIS
BILL IS IMPORTANT TO MINIMIZE
THE ECONOMIC DAMAGE THE INDUSTRY
DOES ON ITS WAY OUT THE DOOR.
OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION IS A
PUBLIC NUISANCE. NO COMPENSATION
IS WARRANTED WHERE THE
COMMISSION ACTS. TO ABATE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND CLIMATE HARMS
THESE LEASES AND THE REMAINING
ACTIVE OFFSHORE PLATFORMS POSE
ONGOING AND UNACCEPTABLE THREATS
TO CALIFORNIA'S $44 BILLION
COASTAL ECONOMY, THE RISKS OF
ANOTHER SPILL AND RELATED
CATASTROPHIC COST TO THE STATE
ARE NOT MENTIONED IN THE IN THE
COMMITTEE REPORT, BUT THEY
ESCALATE EACH YEAR WITH HIS
AGING, CORRODED INFRASTRUCTURE
AND RECENT HIGH PROFILE
BANKRUPTCIES UNDERSCORE THE NEED
TO ACT TO PROTECT PUBLIC FUNDS.
THE COST TO DECOMMISSION AND
REMOVE THE PLATFORMS AND OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE INTO IMMEDIATE
THE AREA ARE THE LEGAL
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE INDUSTRY
AND LIKELY EXCEED FOR A FUTURE
PROFITS FROM THEIR CONTINUED
OPERATION, WITH OIL REVENUES IN
CALIFORNIA, MAKING A SHARP
DOWNTURN, ALLOWING OPERATORS TO
CONTINUE TO DRILL PROLONGS THE
SIGNIFICANT RISK TO THE STATE
AND OUR CURRENT FISCAL SITUATION
SITUATION DEMANDS OF THE
POLLUTERS PAY FOR THEIR CLEANUP
AND DON'T DUMP THEIR COSTS AND
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU. WOULD
YOU LIKE A QUESTION? SURE I HAVE
NO PRIDE EASY ONE OR A HARD ONE.
GO FOR IT PROBABLY WON'T GET
EITHER. THE HARD ONE IS WHO
WROTE THE FIRST DICTIONARY.
MARIAM ROBERT COWDERY. ANYBODY
KNOW THAT? THAT WAS A HARD ONE.
THE EASY ONE. THE EASY ONE IS
WHO WAS THE FIRST WOMAN TO WIN
THE NOBEL PRIZE THAT MARIE
CURIE. ALL RIGHT. ALRIGHT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANY
OPPOSITION. MR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, PAUL DE ERO,
REPRESENTING THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION. WE HAVE A
FUNDAMENTAL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. WE BELIEVE THE MANDATORY
MANDATORY TERMINATION OF
OFFSHORE LEASES WILL IN STATE
WATERS WOULD ESSENTIALLY BE A
TAKING. WE HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
THE FREE AND NEGOTIATIONS
BETWEEN THE PARTIES. BUT THE
BILL WOULD IF THERE IS NO
AGREEMENT, THERE WOULD BE A
MANDATORY TERMINATION OF THE
OFFSHORE LEASES ARE ESTIMATES
THAT THE STATE LIABILITY WOULD
BE BETWEEN 260 MILLION AND 330
MILLION BASED ON THE PRICE OF
CRUDE AT THE TIME. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE IN OPPOSITION? DO
YOU WANT AN EASY ONE OR A HARD
ONE? EASY ONE GOING TO GIVE YOU
A HARD LUNCH. OKAY JUST BECAUSE
YOU'RE BECAUSE YOU'RE AN
OPPOSITION. WHAT ARE
CINDERELLA'S STEPSISTERS NAMES?
CINDERELLA'S STEPSISTERS NAMES.
I DON'T KNOW, ANYBODY KNOW.
THERE YOU GO. SHE GOT BOTHERED
THEM. THAT WAS HARD. ALRIGHT.
ANYONE ELSE SUPPOSED TO 559
SEEING? NONE. DO MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ON 559? SEEING NONE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. 559 WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. SB 571 ALLEN ON FIRE
SAFETY REGULATIONS, DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS AND EGRESS AND EGRESS,
INGRESS AND EGRESS ROUTES
STANDARDS. IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. THE AUTHOR IS WAIVED
PRESENTATION AND WE WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENT HERE FOR
SUPPORT, SEEING NO ONE RUSHED TO
THE MICROPHONE AND SUPPORT WE
WILL GO TO OPPOSITION AND 571
SEEING NO. ARE YOU MOVING OUT?
ALRIGHT QUESTIONS WERE TOO HARD.
ALRIGHT SEEING NO OPPOSITION
WILL COME BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES
AND 571 SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION. 571 WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. ALL RIGHT, MOVING
ON TO SB 575 WAHAB ON MARRIAGE,
UNDERAGE MARRIAGE. IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. THE AUTHOR
HAS WEIGHED PRESENTATION. WE
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING
FOR SUPPORT ON 575 SEEING NO ONE
HERE IN SUPPORT. HOW ABOUT
OPPOSITION, SAYING NO
OPPOSITION? SO WE'LL COME BACK
TO THE DAIS. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION. SP
575 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AND
WE WILL MOVE ON TO WE'RE GOING
TO SKIP ARE THE NEXT 1625. WE'RE
GOING TO DO THAT LAST SO WE CAN
GET THROUGH THE REST OF THE
BUSINESS. SO WE'RE GOING OUT OF
ORDER. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO 733
GLASER. AH WHICH IS ON SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT. WE'LL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING. IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. THE AUTHOR'S WAY
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF 733 SEEING
NO ONE IN SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION
ON 733. NO BUDDY HERE WILL COME
BACK TO MY COLLEAGUE'S ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON 733.
SEEING NONE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
733 WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. SB 869
GLASER COMMERCIAL FINANCING.
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE, THE
AUTHOR'S WAY PRESENTATION. WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
SEVEN EXCUSE ME, 869. THERE'S NO
ONE HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
HOW ABOUT OPPOSITION? THERE IS
NO OPPOSITION, SO THAT OBJECTION
869 WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AND
AGAIN FOR FOLKS FINANCES HERE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS, BUT HAS NO
FILES ON ANY OF THE BILLS. BUT
WE WILL PUT MICHELLE ON THE SPOT
AND ASK A QUESTION SINCE
FINANCES HERE. I WAS SURPRISED.
I DIDN'T THINK THIS WAS THE
ANSWER TO THIS QUESTION. BUT
WHAT IS THE SINGLE BIGGEST
SELLING MUSIC SINGLE? OF ALL
TIME. I ALWAYS THOUGHT IT WAS
WHITE CHRISTMAS, BUT IT'S NOT.
I'M SURPRISED BY THIS ONE IS A
HINT. IT'S UM SOMEBODY WHO WAS
RECENTLY AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
MARIAH CAREY NÓ. EVERYBODY GIVE
UP. CANDLE IN THE WIND. WOW I
DIDN'T KNOW THAT SURPRISED ME. I
THOUGHT IT WAS STAIRWAY TO
HEAVEN AND WHITE CHRISTMAS, BUT
IT'S ACTUALLY CANDLE IN THE WIND
WHO KNEW ANYWAY? LET'S MOVE ON
TO 875 HEALTHCARE FACILITIES,
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY. IT'S A GLASER BILL.
IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE, THE
AUTHOR'S WAY PRESENTATION AND IT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE SUPPORT. YES
ROXANNE GOLD, REPRESENTING SIX
BEDS, WHICH IS AN ASSOCIATION OF
SMALL SIX BEDS OR FEWER
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY IN SUPPORT. AND YOU
WANT EASY OR HARD, ROXANNE HARD.
LET'S GO HARD, ALL RIGHT. WHICH
FORMER NBA PLAYER WAS NICKNAMED
AGENT ZERO. CHAMBERLAIN.
BRADFORD CIERTO. ANYBODY NOW?
GILBERT ARENAS. AGENT ZERO
ALRIGHT? ANYBODY ELSE IN
SUPPORT. OF 875. ANY OPPOSITION
DATE 75. NO OPPOSITION. ANYBODY
HERE? HOW MANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS, SAYING NO OBJECTION
WILL MOVE 8752 SUSPENSE. SB 764
PADILLA, MINORS ONLINE PLATFORMS
AND WILL OPEN UP THE IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. THE AUTHOR'S
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENT. THERE'S NO
ONE HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION TO 764. SEEING NO
OPPOSITION WILL COME BACK TO THE
DAIS. ANYBODY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
ON 764 SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION. 764 WILL MOVE
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE. SB 768
CABALLERO, CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT, STATE
AIR RESOURCE FOR RESOURCES BOARD
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED STUDY
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. THE AUTHOR'S
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
PUBLIC COMMENT. HERE SAYING NO
ONE COMMON SUPPORT. HOW ABOUT
OPPOSITION TO 768? NO OPPOSITION
WILL COME BACK TO THE DAIS.
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WITHOUT OBJECTION. 768 WILL MOVE
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE. OUR FINAL
BILL IS FROM FINAL BILL THAT
WE'RE THEN WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO 625 IS 784 BECKER.
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS EMPLOYMENT.
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE, THE
AUTHOR'S WAY PRESENTATION. WE'RE
GOING TO OPEN UP PUBLIC COMMENT
WITH SUPPORT. SEEING NO SUPPORT,
AND I THINK WE HAVE OPPOSITION
TO 784. SO COME ON UP. I'M
SORRY. YOUR SUPPORT SUPPORT.
LET'S DO SUPPORT. SORRY ABOUT
THAT GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. RYAN BURDICK
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION AND THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS. IN SUPPORT
OF SB 784, A BILL THAT GIVES
HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS THE
ABILITY TO DIRECTLY EMPLOYED
PHYSICIANS. THIS IS A STRONG
TOOL AND HELPING RECRUIT AND
RETAIN PHYSICIANS AND TO HELP
CLOSE THE PHYSICIAN SHORTAGE GAP
THAT WE HAVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
SO WITH THAT WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU EASIER HARD. I'LL DO
AN EASY ONE, UNEASY ONE. ALRIGHT
WHICH IS THE ONLY FOOTBALL TEAM
TO GO IN ENTIRE SEASON
UNDEFEATED. THAT'S THE NEW
ENGLAND PATRIOTS. MHM AN ENTIRE
SEASON MIAMI DOLPHINS SUPER BOWL
SUPER BOWL. GOT IT? YEAH THAT
WAS THE EASY ONE. ALRIGHT I GOT
IT WRONG TO RUN. ALRIGHT ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION AND YOU GOT IT,
YOU KNOW? MR CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE BRANDON MARCHI,
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION WANT TO THANK YOU AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR
THOROUGH ANALYSIS AND WHAT I
ASKED FOR YOUR NO VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT, EASY OR HARD. OH CHOICE
ALRIGHT, WHICH TWO COUNTRIES
HAVE NOT MISSED A MODERN
OLYMPICS, ONLY TWO COUNTRIES
HAVE BEEN IN EVERY SINGLE
OLYMPICS. IN THE MODERN TIMES.
HARD WON. YEAH, IT IS A HARD
ONE. I I'M GONNA GO WITH ENGLAND
AND FRANCE. THAT'S WRONG, THOUGH
, ABOUT GREECE AND AUSTRALIA,
ALL RIGHT, THE ONLY TWO THAT
HAVEN'T RESCUE WANT AN EASY ONE.
NO YAHOO'S ONE MORE TENNIS GRAND
SLAMS VENUS OR SERENA. SERENA
SERENA, SEE, I TOLD YOU IT WAS
AN EASY ONE. ALRIGHT UM, WE HAVE
TAKEN SUPPORTING OPPOSITION 784
WITH NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION,
784. WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE. WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO SB 625
SENATOR NGUYEN ON NEWBORN
SCREENING SCREENING GENETIC
DISEASES. IT'S THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. THE AUTHOR WANTS TO
PRESENT SO. WHEREVER WHEREVER
YOU'RE COMFORTABLE. YEAH. THANK
YOU, MR CHAIRMAN. SENATORS I'M
HERE TO PRESENT SB 2625 AND THE
COMMENTS I WOULD MAKE IS REALLY
TALK, TOUCHING ON WHETHER THIS
WOULD BE A COST. TO THE STATE OR
NOT. SP 265 CLARIFIES AND
EXPANDS THE LAW RELATIVE TO
HANDLING BLOOD SAMPLES THAT ARE
TAKEN FROM NEWBORN BABIES DOING
GENETIC SCREENING TEST IS FOR
TREATABLE INHERITED CONDITIONS
AND DISABILITIES. CURRENT LAW
MANDATES THAT ALL INFANT BORN IN
CALIFORNIA SCREEN FOR INHERITED
CONDITION THAT CAN BE TREATED IF
IDENTIFIED EARLY. SB 65 DOES
NOTHING TO CHANGE. THE CURRENT
LAW REGARDING THE SCREENING TEST
. HOWEVER CURRENT LAW IS VAGUE
ABOUT WHAT CAN AND WILL BE DONE
WITH THE LEFTOVER BLOOD SAMPLES
AFTER THE SCREENING TEST HAS
BEEN COMPLETED AND BEING KNOWN
TO MOST PEOPLE, INCLUDING
MYSELF. WHEN I HAD MY TWO BOYS,
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY RETAINED
AND STORED THOSE BLOOD SAMPLES
FOR AN INDEFINITELY INDEFINITE
PERIOD OF TIME AND ALLOWS THEM
TO BE USED BY RESEARCHERS. SP 65
WILL ALLOW PARENTS TO OPT OUT OF
THE PROCESS RETAIL OF THE OF THE
PROCESS OF RETAINING STORY AND
USING THEIR BABIES BLOODS FOR
RESEARCH. PURPOSES IF THEY SO
DESIRE. IT ALSO MAKES OTHER
CHANGES THAT CLARIFY THE
AUTHORITY OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
MANAGE INFANT BLOOD SAMPLES.
CURRENT LAW AUTHORIZES THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
COLLECT FEES TO COVER THE COST
OF THE SCREENING TESTS. THESE
FEES ARE NEARLY ALWAYS BILLED
AND COLLECTED BY THE BIRTHING
CENTERS WHERE THE MOTHER
DELIVERS THE BABY. THIS IS MOST
OFTEN ULTIMATELY PAID BY HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES ESTIMATE
COST TO IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS
OF SB 6 TO 5 WILL REMAIN THE
SAME. AS WILL BE IN WILL BE
PAYING THE SAME WAY. UM I WANT
TO MAKE CLEAR THAT S SPEECH. 65
WILL HAVE NO IMPACT ON THE STATE
GENERAL FUN NOR THE ESTIMATED
BUDGET DEFICIT CALIFORNIA
SLIGHTLY FACING THIS FISCAL YEAR
. SB 65 REQUIRES THAT AN
INFORMATIONAL BROCHURE THAT IS
CURRENTLY BEING GIVEN TO
EXPECTANT PARENTS TO BE MODIFIED
TO INCLUDE MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE FUTURE, USE THEIR
CHILD'S BLOOD SAMPLE. TO BEING
INCLUDED TO INCLUDE BEING USED
FOR RESEARCH PURPOSES BY THIRD
PARTY RESEARCHERS. SO SB 65
THERE IS CURRENTLY INFORMATIONAL
BROCHURE ALREADY. ALL THIS DOES
IS JUST ADD SOME MORE
INFORMATION ON TO THE BUSH.
SURE, SO THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL
COSTS IN TERMS OF ADDING A
BROCHURE. IT'S ALREADY THERE. UM
SO IT'S REALLY THE ONE TIME
COSTS IS THE UM, DESIGN AND
ETCETERA JUST AT THE INFORMATION
IN AGAIN, THIS WOULD BE A ONE
TIME COST BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT
ALREADY ANNUAL HANDS OUT OVER
500,000 FORMS PER YEAR. THE NEW
COSTS WOULD ALSO AS WOULD BE
JUST TOO. REDESIGNED THE
PRESSURE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HELP ADVERTISERS THAT
PARENTS MAY REQUEST THAT THEIR
CHILD'S BLOOD SAMPLES BE
DESTROYED. THIS PROCESS NOTHING
MORE THAN A POLICY THAT IS NOT
THAT IS NOT INCORPORATED EITHER
STATUTE OR REGULATION. TODAY S B
6 TO 5 QUALIFIES THIS POLICY
WITH THE ADDED INFORMATION BUT
THE ADDED REQUIREMENT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT NOTIFY THE PARENTS
WITHIN 30 DAYS THAT THE SAMPLE
HAS IN FACT BEEN DESTROYED AS
REQUESTED. HOWEVER SINCE THIS IS
CURRENT POLICY, ADDITIONAL
EMPLOYEES SHOULD NOT BE
NECESSARY SINCE THE DEPARTMENT'S
ALREADY CONFORMING TO THEIR OWN
POLICY. AGAIN ALL THESE COSTS
SHOULD BE COVERED BY THE FEES
CHARGED AND COLLECTED CURRENTLY
ALREADY BY THE BIRTHING CENTERS
FOR THE INITIATIVE, SCREENING
TESTS. NO NEW OR ADDITIONAL
COSTS WILL BE INCURRED. ER UH,
THE DEPARTMENT CHARGES
RESEARCHER FOR THE FOR THE USE
OF THESE SAMPLES AS WELL. SO IN
CONCLUSION, I AM JUST ASKING, UM
WELL IN CONCLUSION. SB 65 WILL
INCREASE WILL ONLY HELP TO
INCREASE PARENTAL INFORMATION
AND EMPOWER THEM TO LIMIT THE
USE OF THEIR BABY'S BLOOD
SAMPLE. AFTER IF THEY CHOOSE TO
DO SO, WHAT? NO ADDITIONAL COSTS
. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON SB 65 AND MR CHAIR IS
FOR THE RECORD. THIS IS MY FIRST
TIME EVER IN THAT WAVING MY
BECAUSE THIS IS WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS BILL FOR TWO
YEARS, AND I REALLY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THOSE COMMENTS SO
EVERYBODY KNOWS. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES? I DON'T KNOW. IS
THERE OPPOSITION? NO YOUR
OPPOSITION SUPPORT COME TESTIFY
AND SUPPORT. VOICE ROXANNE GOLD,
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN NURSES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT, AND I
HAVE A TRIVIA QUESTION FOR YOU.
ALRIGHT NURSES HAVE BEEN THE
MOST TRUSTED PROFESSION FOR THE
LAST 22 YEARS WHO DID THE UNSEAT
FIREFIGHTERS? THERE YOU GO. IT
WAS A HOSPITAL TAKEOVER BRAWLING
NURSE VERSUS FIREFIGHTERS. I HAD
NOTHING TO DO THAT ONE SO 22
YEARS. GOOD QUESTION. ALRIGHT
ANYONE ELSE OR YOU HAVE SOMEBODY
BEHIND YOU? ALL RIGHT. COME ON
UP. TWEENERS WILL TAKE GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR RON BIRD EGO
HERE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WITH THE
AMENDMENTS FROM JANUARY 11TH.
PLEASED TO MOVE OUR POSITION TO
NEUTRAL, APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
WORKING WITH US TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS. UM AND THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME. EASY ONE OR A HARD
ONE. YOU KNOW, I LOOK MIGHT AS
WELL GO FOR THE HARD WON. ALL
RIGHT, UM DUMP FLOATER AND WIPE
ARE TERMS USED IN WHICH SPORT
OH, NO CLUE. VOLLEYBALL.
HOLLYWOOD REALLY? WIPE. DUMP
FLOATER AND WIPE ARE TERMS USED
IN WHICH TEAM SUPPORT BATHROOM.
ALRIGHT ANYONE ELSE SUPPOSED WHO
SAYS GOVERNMENT IS BORING? NOT
IN THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE,
ALL RIGHT. NO OTHER COMMENTS.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 625 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. THAT IS ALL WE
HAVE ON OUR FILE, MR WIENER.
I'VE GOT ONE HARD QUESTION LEFT
FOR YOU. JUST BECAUSE YOU WERE
LATE, WHICH COUNTRY WHICH
COUNTRY DOES GOUDA CHEESE
ORIGINATED? UM. WHO KNOWS WHO
INVENTED GOUDA CHEESE. THE
NETHERLANDS GIVE YOU SOME HELP.
NETHERLANDS THERE YOU GO,
NETHERLANDS. ALRIGHT WITHOUT
FURTHER COMMENTS, THIS MEETING
IS ADJOURNED.